هذه اول الصور التي نتابعها مشاهدينا صور
للتصاعد الدخان لعمليه
نفاذتها اسرائيل في خان يونس استهدفت قائد
الوحده الصاروخيه بسرايا القدس التابعه
لحركه الجهات خالد الفره وهذه الصور
الاوليه لهذا الاستهداف الذي ذكرناه قبل
قليل لقصف خان يونس
واستهدف كما ذكرنا خالد الفرقه قائد
الوحده الصاروخيه بسرايا القدس التابعه
لحركه الجهاد وقد نقلت ايضا مصادر
الفلسطينيه بان هناك اصابات اخرى
عند استهداف هذه السياره كما جاء في
المعلومات الاوليه حتى الان
[موسيقى]
هذه صوره اذا للسياره التي تم استهداف
خالد الفره داخلها
وتشتغل فيها النيران كما نلاحظ في الصور
استهداف مباشر
وقصف لسياره خالد الفراق قائد الوحده
الصاروخيه بسرايا القدس التابعه لحركه
الجهاد اذا هو استهداف اخر في قطاع غزه في
خان يونس هذه المره اضافه الى استهداف
الذي تم فجر اليوم واستهدفت ثلاثه من قاده
حركه الجهاد
في سرايا القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد
هذه الصور الاوليه التي جاءت قبل قليل
وكنا قد ذكرنا بان مصادر الفلسطينيه تحدثت
عن وجود اصابات اخرى عدا عن استهداف خالد
الفره قائد الوحده الصاروخيه بسرايا القدس
التابعه لحركه الجهاد